hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
where i hannah pearl react to different
videos that are requested of me
today i am reacting to kevin samuels um
let me look at the title of the video
mother of two believes that she is the
prize
can only guess what that means how this
is gonna go
um but before i begin do not forget to
like comment
and subscribe especially subscribe again
the more subscribers i am
oh my gosh the more subscribers that i
have the more motivated
i am to keep making content all right so
let me switch the scenes
all right
22 minutes
all right i'm coming back to you guys
ipad 2 whatever your name is
a mute yourself hello
hi hi okay so very nice to meet you
i am new to your channel so
um just kind of following along so
first up let's start let's start with
this what's your name
my name's susan hi susan how old are you
i'm 30. all right what you got for me
so i'm 30 and i have two kids so i'm
single i have two kids
from a previous relationship so i was
kind of trying to rape myself
but i am still like very like young
active i have a lot to offer um i make
great money
i have good well-behaved children and i
am
in la dating and i just find dating in
la
so hard so i actually don't have like a
problem
like meeting like um what you call like
high profile men like men you just got a
problem getting a husband
yeah but yeah cause you got two kids
so it's just the two kids you know it's
not just
it's not just it's not just it's big
i mean you're 30 years old and all this
career stuff where
uh how many how many different fathers
one
okay how come how come you and he didn't
get married i was so young
when i was in that relationship so how
is your oldest child
10. i was your youngest
seven so you were 23.
when i had my daughter yeah so my kid's
father he was older than me
but listen what i'm about to say you
were younger you were
old enough to make babies first one at
20.
even though i'm not okay with it you can
let it slide but the second one man
that's a choice
why didn't you yeah no we were in the
like i was with him for like
six or seven years but you weren't his
wife
and that's now yeah so so
if you let me explain it to you i'll try
you're a woman that was with a man for
six or seven years
and you gave him the highest honor a
woman can give
any man on the planet you gave him
children
you gave him not only one you gave him
two and yet you did not require him to
even bestow the title of a wife upon you
so you go back out into the market older
with two children you and you expect
someone in that market
to accept you older and bestow the title
of life upon you
that's what that's how men look at it
right wrong or indifferent and then
being in la
one of the most competitive markets for
women in the world
competition is stiff out there i'll be
there in a couple of weeks
beautiful woman on every corner like so
i
do me i do me okay
i agree with the kids thing asking like
having kids is a lot to ask of anybody
like to be a step parent
for kids in our ears i'm not saying it's
impossible to find love but you have to
realize that that's going to be a factor
when you're dating
um on top of that she's in l.a
i agree like when i went to l.a oh my
gosh there's so many beautiful people
like yeah i agree great men
i don't think it's hard finding the man
so like
okay man i admit it too oh no no no see
this is how we judge over here
we don't judge by dealing with dating we
judging weddings
that's the only thing that counts if
you're not married you're losing
see that makes it real clear because
you've had
everything up to that point anyway right
i've been engaged right i don't count
those either
because women especially a lot of black
women
have been engaged for a long time three
four five engagements see when you make
it real clear
there's a high value man or whatever you
do whatever
term you're using has any one of them
marry you
and the answer is no
that like hurt me for her that hurt me
for her
and that's what i say it's the dating
market is difficult because
you're not an unattractive woman sure a
guy will take you out for a
nice date
you really know what you really want to
know what we think
uh how tall are you i'm five six i weigh
115 pounds
yes oh yeah i'll take you out i'll hell
yeah i would take you
oh i don't have a problem finding
mention of course not i wouldn't
but the thing is but what do you find in
the four though
yeah i would take you out take you out
get you a nice steak and some lobster
we'd have a good old time and i would
blow your
back out but i wouldn't marry you
oh you're back damn
damn
see what i think i really have an issue
is like
finding men that don't want like the
superficial like
most i feel like the type of guys like
they just
want a woman that like looks good on
their arm like
yes she is not listening
so like when you don't listen let me
stop stop stop stop stop stop stop stop
stop
stop right there yes that's what we want
because that's who we are
and you want a man that's the problem
but listen listen listen listen
listen you want men
not to be men you want men to think
like women that's not what we value
ma'am
we want a beautiful woman on our arm
yeah that's the problem well yes
no you're the problem i'm the problem
yes you're the problem because i'm
telling you what
men want you've experienced what
men want and you've got a problem with
it that's your problem
we're not going to change you're either
going to get on board with it
or you will die alone okay so what
should i
be looking for then well honestly first
you need to get down and understand that
you have no leverage you have no
leverage in this matter
it's the men we control access to
relationships you control access to sex
you need to understand what a man that
you would want
what he would want in a girlfriend wife
or significant other
like a good like a good mother
um that changes from every man
that changes from man to man where's
your father
oh i don't i don't have i didn't grow up
with a mother or a father
all right so due respect
you you you've you don't seem to get
that men judge the way we judge
and yes like i said you have no problem
getting men to pay you
attention you've got no problem
attracting men
but getting a man to take you seriously
and would you like to be married
i would okay and that's a problem
because you're asking a man to become a
stepfather
you're asking let's say you're asking me
to come in and take care of one man's
child
a man's two children
okay i didn't create those
it's all downside i've been a stepfather
it's a
horrible deal what about the men that
have children of their own
they want a stepmother
well again you still act as though
you're not commenting
okay listen i'll answer it see you still
you're still speaking as if you have
leverage in this thing and i'm trying to
level set you
even if i have children i got more
options than you
i can go find a woman with no kids
because i can afford both of you
if i can afford if i can afford to take
care of you and your kids
i can afford to take care of her and no
kids
yeah why would i pick you and your kids
when i know your kids are not going to
i'm not their father i wonder if this
changes like if the kids are a little
older
like if the kids are already 18 like out
of the house
they'll never look at me as their father
i got all the responsibility
and none of the upside of being a
biological father can i discipline those
children like they were my own
they don't need to discipline their
bodies i see that's your problem there
you go right there
she said they don't need this at all
okay this is why
this is why shh
if you're in freaking sane if you don't
think children
your kids are not special they need
discipline
just like anyone else maybe you don't
okay
then this is the problem i don't need
discipline so the answer is
could i could i discipline the child
yeah
okay without without quit without you
questioning me
yeah if i'm like if i choose you as my
partner like
i'm have complete trust in you okay so i
could so i could spank the children
attend
they don't need spain no no no no i
could spank that see see right there
i said i could discipline children you
said yes
pay attention woman i am damn
you said i could discipline the children
without you questioning me
yes so if i decide to spank them i gotta
listen to your mouth
because they don't need it that's why
you need to stay single until your kids
are gone
that's the choice you made when you
reproduced man
and i need you ladies to understand
that's actually what i was thinking like
you know i mean i have a sister who was
remarried and she like ended up marrying
a guy with
kids so like they had like a blended
family and it was fine
so i mean i hear what he's saying like
maybe like a high value man
but there's like again like nerdy like
other like nice guys
that are out there that have kit like
isn't
okay i thought i heard on one of these
podcasts like 90 like 10 percent of men
get all the girls so
that mean leaves 90 of that
maybe 80 70 60 for her but like
couldn't she just like state a little
bit more strategically
like maybe go for a guy that maybe
doesn't have as much money
but like is kind caring has a good heart
whatever
especially if she's already providing
for her kids on her own
something you going out here having
babies without marriage
and then breaking up with men you incur
consequences we don't want those kids
around us because we cannot take care of
them
cannot discipline them we don't want to
put up with all this other stuff
you're a fun woman guys look at you and
be like she's got two kids and she's
5 6 115. she's a lot of fun she's
obviously sexually active i'll have a
good time with you
but no way god no no not no way but very
unlikely the man is going to take you
seriously especially when you start
talking
oh god because i believe what you're
telling me is honestly and i'm like who
wants this deal who doesn't want this
deal
a beautiful woman that is a great mother
has a great career don't care about
don't care about your career strong like
i'm submissive
nobody but listen did you did you hear
what i just said did you just
okay did you hear what i just said don't
care about your career
yeah the thing is ma'am it's the two
kids
that's the two kids everything you're
saying does not
overcome the deficit that two children
bring
if you if i mean like you have money
that doesn't matter to you
i said you have money that doesn't
matter to you if i have more
i have more more more money i have more
money than you
i have more money than i have more money
and i can go over there and get her and
she's 25
she has no kids and i don't have to go i
don't have to deal with any of the stuff
we just talked about
she's 25 agreeable cooperative fit
and ready to get on my program have butt
naked freaky circus sex
and she's happy to be there and
experience all these new things i'm
dealing with a 30 year old woman who's
got
her mind listen i'm lit okay
see when this when this conversation is
over i go back to my wonderful life
you go back to your life still trying to
figure these things out and i'm just
trying to help you lady
i'm not saying you're not everything
you're saying you all sit down for
the next like eight years but you're not
okay
and who is actively pursuing you to be
their wife
i mean i got options who is actively
pursuing
they're not good options if she's not in
a relationship
you to be their wife
i've got options i just don't really
ma'am you didn't no
no that would be a fiancee
see this is where the truth comes in you
can either ex
man you don't have these kind of options
and i'm trying to explain okay then you
wouldn't be here
if you actually had options of the kind
of the kind and caliber of men
that you want then they were really
considering you to be
their wife you wouldn't be here right
now
i know i'm i'm just kind of like
learning about
i mean i'm new here so i've this is
literally like my first time like really
well
but the thing is ma'am you're still a on
your baby mama of
two and
are you telling me you're dating someone
seriously
oh i yeah i i always have options
i'm going to ask you one more time and
if you are vague i'm going to bid you a
good night just asking you are you
dating someone
seriously yeah
how long have you guys been seeing one
another um it's been like
two years two years
has he expressed any desire to make you
his wife
yes has he taken you ring shopping in
the last
two years we've been ring shopping yeah
when
about three months ago three months ago
but to say the guy that
like really just like sparks like
my i don't know it just doesn't feel
like
someone i want to be with forever so
that's that's so i go back to the first
thing i
asked you dating sir it's like these
girls don't listen to his questions
are you telling me you are seeing
someone then they're the man who's
actually considering you
is the man you want to be with and you
said i've got options
and you just went through this
convoluted way of getting back down to
i got somebody in there playing my love
life well well no ma'am
what it is it's hard for you to deal
with the truth what it is is
one you don't have
a man that you want considering you
to be his wife you got a man that you
don't want
who sounds like he would take you but
you don't want to marry him
that's why it's been two years
this is why you're on here trying to
figure it out and i'm only trying to
help you but it seems like you'd rather
argue or be right than listen no i'm not
trying to argue
okay well then i need you to understand
that your children
are a massive impediment how about this
would you like to have additional
children i would
how many oh maybe two
one to two so let's say you and i were
to get married okay
what you automatically said i don't know
why i feel like she kind of likes him
oh it is you get pregnant on our wedding
night and you get pregnant you give
birth to kevin junior
then a year or a year after that you
give birth to
kim kevin and kim are my biological
children with you right
okay then i still have to take care of
your
two other children right so we have four
four kids in the house yeah kevin and
kim
are mine if i decide to spank kevin
you can't say [ __ ] to me because he's
mine biologically
you can't tell me listen okay
you're going to sit there and zip your
mouth and let me get through the example
before you say something can you do that
give me a minute
kevin and cam are mine they're my
financial responsibility and you cannot
pull the mommy card on me because
biologically you can't you can't one-up
me you can't play the high joker
you can't say these those aren't but
when it comes to your
children they're your children
i've got to discipline them in line with
what you
think is right so i got two kid two sets
of kids in the house under two sets of
rules
that's madness i've seen it
no one men don't want that man
can you understand that
that's the problem with being a having
children
already because you would have two kids
by me
two kids over here but yet if they want
to go to college
i'm still supposed to pay for it your
children want to go to college i still i
got to put a roof over their head food
in their bellies and provide for them
just like i was providing for kevin and
kim
except kevin and kim let's say you and i
divorced
kevin and kim are mine i still got
visitation
do i necessarily have anything with
those kids if you decide not to
let me see my step kids you could cut
that bond
you ladies never think of it from a
man's side it's all
i've seen that i like oh my gosh i heard
about this mom
where the dad like the step-dad
literally raised the kid for like 10
years
and the mom like wouldn't let him see
the kids
which is nuts to me because this man
like
saw your kids for a decade oh what you
want
and like you said you want a man to not
be into all this superficial stuff
another
which means you really don't give a damn
what we
think we're just supposed to come in and
do what you need
that's fine but you better be offering a
hell of a deal
and now you have to hear that only
because of the kids
well all kids are big man you can't
only big i mean and here's the thing you
do have the option
because you say only cause of the kids
but that's a big deal yeah
yeah would you date so you dating a
woman with children is like off the
table for you i married a woman with a
child ma'am i understand what i'm
talking about am i just doing
no i would not date a woman with a child
no i felt like she kind of likes him
i don't know i just
i've been there and the thing is where's
the children's father
oh i left him where is he alive
yeah is he involved in the children's
life at all
yeah then if you really are serious
give custody to the father go off with
your go off with your new husband and
make a new family
see no i couldn't do that well well then
guess
what buy a dog and wait till they're out
of the house man because
i've talked about women like you all the
time you're not willing to give anything
up i asked you about discipline they
don't need this they don't need that
give up custody i don't can't do that
ma'am you're not
fit i mean no disrespect man but you're
not really
fit to be with somebody you want someone
to fit into your
particular jagged life and why would
a man who has options choose that
just because you're attractive i mean
you're attractive but
but in la that's a dime a dozen
i mean you you'd have to understand that
though
i no i do know that but i think i'm more
simple than just the way i look
what i said i'm i'm definitely more
valuable than
just my lips granted granted i'm never
seeing that you're not
like i'm from the midwest i'm a good
midwestern girl i'm not a
little girl i'm not uh i'm from oklahoma
ma'am i'm from the midwest too but what
i'm saying
is but you can't expect someone who
doesn't know you to know that
like they have to get to know you first
so
like it's kind of tough okay let's try
it this way
i what would the man what was the kind
of man that you want what would he want
from a woman from a wife
from a wife he he would
i think what i value
like just at the end of the day is just
like pure connection like do i
like no shared values
no like
life plan like okay no don't
love it's just love there's nothing else
like
but you can't rely on just feelings
because if you rely on feelings alone
like
those run out at some point like people
drive you crazy even if you love them
i i'm very very family oriented i have
nine siblings i love them all
to death but like they drive me nuts my
sister has been texting me this whole
time
asking me to go get her chips no
i don't want to go get your tips like
do i want this person do i look
like look up to this person is do i feel
like this
person is a good person is you know do
we share the same values
as you know okay values like moral
is there laughter joy excitement what
does he want from a wife ma'am and you
gave me
oh what does he want from like just a
wife like maybe just a good
housewife a woman that cooks for her
okay ma'am so let me ask you a question
will your mother and father marry
no all right then it's
then you were not raised to be a
housewife no i don't think i
definitely was not raised for you though
housewife that's for sure
but listen listen listen i'm hoping that
dream then i'll find the right person if
you i'ma slap the smack out of you i'll
let you go man but you cannot overtalk
me
i'm trying to be nice man but you're not
gonna do that
look you weren't raised to be a
housewife
and you just said the kind of man that
you would want what he wanted as a good
housewife
then he wouldn't want you cause you're
not one
by your own admission you're not one
i wasn't raised to be one which means
you're not
one but i had great influences
if you had such great influences why
someone
[Music]
damn
um i don't really have much to add like
i don't disagree with anything he said
like sometimes
choices you make lead to like sad
realities later
and you know i don't have kids or
anything but like
i've definitely faced the repercussions
of choices that i've made before
and you can either like deal with it and
try to make the best of it
or you can just argue and act like
there's no repercussions but
let me know in the comments did i get it
right did i get it wrong
and let me know what i should what kevin
samuels video i should react to next
time
thanks so much guys bye